رغم هذا
الالم ابدا بطمان ابناء
امتنا وابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني الصابر
الابي ان مقاومته المضفره هي بخير بل بالف
خير فلا تزال تقود وتدير فصول معركه طوفان
الاقصى في يومه الاني والستين بكل قوه
وحكمه
واقتدار تسطر فيها ملحمه طوله وهي تدافع
عن شعبها وارضها وقدسها واقصاها المبارك
وتثخينه
قتلا وجرحا او مصابين
باعاقة ها قطعا متناثره حينا اخر وتحرقها
حتى اخر شيء فيها مره
ثالثه فيما يتفحم فيها الجنود النازيون
القتله الجبناء والمرتزقه الذين ياتون من
اقاع العالم المختلفه ليشاركوا في جريمه
العصر التي ترتكب في
غزه وبينما يتم توثيق تدمير مئات الاليات
العسكريه الصهيونيه كليا او جزئيا منذ
بدايه هذا
العدوان وقتل العشرات من الجنود وضباط
الاحتلال وقاده الالويه والسرايا فيه قنصا
او بالعبوات التي
تستهدفهم واعتراف العدو بقتل قرابه المئه
من جنوده وضباطه فان كل هذه الاعترافات لا
تعبر عن حقيقه العدد الحقيقي الذي نحصيه
بشكل دائم كل يوم وان اعترافه بالفي جريح
هو واقل من الرقم الحقيقي الذي يقوله وما
زال مقاومون مستب سلون في الميدان وفي كل
المحاور يخرجون لهذا العدو من تحت الارض
ومن فوقها ومن بين الركام والحطام يدمرون
المدرعات والدبابات وناقلات الجندي
ويقتلون الجنود والضباط وبكل ثقه يوثقون
ذلك بالصوت والصوره ويواصلون فوق كل ذلك
قصف مدنه مستوطناتها لا سما تل ابيب التي
قصفت اول امس برشقه صاروخيه بعد 61 يوما
من العدوان ولا زال في جعبه المقاومه
الكثير وحتى تكون الصوره اكثر وضوحا لما
يبذله القسام في معركه طوفان الاقصى فقد
نجحت المقاومه يوم امس الاربعاء في محوري
خانيونس وبيت لاهيه في تدمير 23 اليه
صهيوني
وفي اليوم الذي سبقه دمرت 24 اليه واجهز
بالقنص المباشر على 18 جنديا اما على
محاور مدينه غزه المدينه فقط وليس القطاع
كاملا فقد دمر مجاهدون خلال 72 ساعه ماضيه
79 اليه بشكل كلي او جزئي